each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen so I
thought it would be a good opportunity
right now to introduce myself at last so
I'm Judith bishop and i am the director
computer science in microsoft research
connections it's probably also a good
opportunity to introduce microsoft
research connections we are the external
research as it was called part of
microsoft research with a part that
actively interacts with academics that's
you most of you and starts off and
amplifies a lot of the engagements
between our researchers and the the work
inside universities we're going to hear
more about that i think when our first
speaker speaks and when we have our
little panel today which is going to
have four of our amazing top executives
from microsoft research I've asked them
to do three things I've asked them
actually to introduce their role and
responsibilities inside Microsoft
themselves rather than me doing it and
I've asked them to do two things one to
talk about two of the challenges that
they see for software in the next 20
years on and what they can see is the
calls to action that us all of us could
look to to reduce any barriers that
would enable us to achieve solutions to
these challenges I keep talking about us
or you or this group and I thought you'd
like to know just some quick statistics
as to who we are so in this room today
we have representatives from 28
countries and actually 125 institutions
of which 25 are industrial
including some of our biggest
competitors so that's rather fun we have
215 attendees and I understand we'll
also have a few guests tonight on our
boat I hope not too many because the
boat takes 230 after which apparently it
will sink so but they have assured us
will be enough life words lifebelts so
without further ado I'm going to call on
our first speaker who is dr. Tony hey
Tony hey is well known of course too
many of you he has a very distinguished
career throughout Britain Europe and of
course America where he has spent the
last 20 years and he is corporate vice
president of microsoft research
connections Tony thank you thank you
very much Judith yes so I'm privileged
to be in charge of I University
collaborations now call microsoft
research connections that just to some
words about my background I went to the
other place I did my undergraduate and
my PhD in Oxford which is I know it's
not popular here and I did a PhD in
theoretical physics but actually my
world was changed when I did a postdoc
at Caltech and I arrived and I was in
the same research group as Richard
Feynman and murray gell-mann Nobel Prize
winners which you rapidly learn in
Oxford that the world revolves a little
bit round Oxford but in Caltech you
rapidly learned that Europe to a first
approximation doesn't exist
so after doing physics the medical
particle physics for 15 years I switched
in the mid-eighties to computing and
I've been doing that for 25 years so
some of my friends almost regard me as a
computer scientist after 25 years what I
started doing was parallel computing and
that's one of the challenges I'm going
to talk about today and I became head of
department of a computer science
department where we taught our students
linux apache my sequel PHP Java eclipse
Perl Python Ruby open source and not
much Microsoft Technology and then after
a short Center dean of engineering I was
very fortunate to be running the uke
science program which was a
multidisciplinary program which is an
opportunity I think for the computer
science community to actually help the
world solve some of its most significant
problems and that was a very exciting
period and that was what essentially I
was brought in by craig mundie to
Microsoft to do was to start a few like
a science at Microsoft program and then
I took on my old community of computer
scientists as well so that's enough
background we do fund projects around
the world in a show in our labs in
Beijing and India we have our microsoft
research connections we have one in
India of course and we also have
activities in Latin America as well as
North America challenges right okay so
I'm slightly depressed about the state
of parallel programming I was one of the
people who wrote the first draft of the
message passing interface MPI it was
made as a standard in 1994 alright so
that's 17 years ago nearly and we
haven't made much progress since I my
introduction to computer science was
slightly idiosyncratic I came under the
influence of tony hoare and david may
and languages like Aachen
which actually taught me the value of a
message passing because you could prove
things like deadlock deadlock freedom
and things like this and I think message
passing is a very much cleaner paradigm
than shared memory when I was at IBM
research I used I was public one of the
first and only uses of the the rp3
shared memory programming and it taught
me all the pitfalls of shared memory and
locks and barriers and things like this
and you certainly can't prove anything
about that so paralyzing is too
difficult for normal mortals could we
ever make it automatic all right well
the group I was in in IBM was trying to
do that it was it was called the patron
group and I was probably the first and
only real user of the patron paralyzing
compiler and programs that have massive
amounts of of geometric parallelism you
know to do with the domain decomposition
in in in XY and Z and so on it could not
pick out obvious parallelism so I became
very pessimistic about automatic
compilers and compilers doing everything
for you so I do personally believe that
we need at this moment an interim
approach through templates where you
have obvious paradigms of parallel
programming that a novice programmer
who's never done any parallel
programming can recognize that their
problem fits this particular pattern and
then you have armies of experts who've
written really good libraries of
parallel programming libraries for these
particular templates and that you need
to be able to do from multi core two
clusters and up to the cloud and so I
think really what you want to be able to
do is to span from multi core to the
cloud transparently and there's one more
ingredient I think you need which is
when you make a choice in paralyzing the
hardware matters and you can have real
bad performance penalties and so you
need to have some idea when you write
your code what the performance penalties
are for your particular hardware
architecture so I think you need
performance prediction in your
programming environment
to understand the choices and trade-offs
so that's I think we haven't got there
yet and really the only things that you
program these massively parallel systems
are either with mpi or now with data
mining with things like mapreduce and I
think it would be good to try and do
better whether we will have succeeded 20
years from now I'm still a little
skeptical but I think we will obviously
have to do that and Bill Gates came past
my office once in Microsoft and he was
lamenting the fact that Microsoft really
have to do parallel programming because
the future really is parallel and we
really as a community need to solve that
so my call to action on that is really
that you know I think the research
funding agencies went to sleep in the
90s not recognizing the importance of
parallelism to the future of IT but now
it's really here and we need to do a
better job the second one is what I call
semantic computing the second challenge
and I lived like that in the National
Library of Medicine abstracts of all the
papers that are published in the
biomedical field not all the biomedical
field but a good percentage of it are
deposited in a thing called medline or
pubmed and if you average out how many
papers are published it comes down to
about two papers a minute are deposited
into medline now there's no way anybody
can keep up with the literature at that
pace and it's going to get worse they're
going to be huge amounts of data there's
going to be huge amounts of paper how
can you make sense of it well I mean one
approaches through what Tim berners-lee
called semantic web where you have
ontology 'he's you have things like rdf
you have logic languages like owl but i
suspect that that life is not quite as
precise as as these logic languages and
ontologies would want and i think
therefore you need a slightly more fuzzy
way of dealing with things is because
nature is a little more less precise
than than than is assumed by these logic
approaches and so I think that really
what semantic computing where semantics
can be
technologies like machine learning which
actually can help you organize help you
get inferences out they know what you're
looking for you have the data when you
deposit it has an annotation which is
machine readable and so if you're
looking for information about Sirius the
star it knows that this data contains
that but that data doesn't and so it
brings back to you relevant data how you
mark up all this data is very
interesting how you mark up the papers
how does the computer understand what
the content of a paper is the content of
a website and you have to give it that
information RDF is one way and you see
now with these data gov type approaches
that the link data my colleagues at
Southampton Nigel Shadbolt Wendy hall
and Jim Hendler that RPI are pushing
things like linked data so these are
very interesting and I was solid I was
unable to go to the session that evil in
organized this afternoon because I think
that's a very important area so the
second challenge is really understanding
how you can get computers to do more
than just compute in store but to
actually help you infer to act on your
behalf and so if you like the Third Age
of computing is the active participation
where the computers actually a part of
the solution they actually filter for
you they can act on your behalf they can
collect data which is relevant to what
you're doing and they can understand
what your intent is so that's I think
the major grand challenge there and I
think that'll be with us for a number of
years and we'll have made some progress
in 20 years but i'm not sure we'll have
completely solved it Judith Johnny so
remember those two parallel computing
and semantic computing so we now have
Andrew Herbert who was speaking to us
this morning and of course his chairman
of Microsoft amia and he's going to give
his view of those topics as well thank
you dude it so I've introduced several
times a day this is time I get to
introduce myself and say what I actually
do which is great so yes I was
my PhD at Cambridge in the days when you
could still get a PhD from writing an
operating system and you could still do
that in about 12 months I think it was
25 thousand lines of code or something
and someone complained it was too long
hey very different era so for the last
10 years I've been managing director of
the Microsoft Research Lab in cambridge
i now have this new role as chairman and
so I still carry some responsibility
towards assisting Andrew Blake as he
runs Cambridge and the the two more
applied research groups in Arkin and
Cairo which is it's fascinating to add
to the portfolio and doing joint
research with customers and getting more
involved in some of the collaborative
programs and more broadly supporting
craig mundie our chief technology our
chief research and strategy officer on
how Microsoft communicates broadly with
governments and similar organizations
like the World Economic Forum to help
them understand what the implications
might be for how technology could
develop how that would impact upon
economics and social affairs what some
of the big questions might turn out to
be that Pollock will cause politicians
to have to respond in regulations and
policy and so forth and what might be
some of the governance structures that's
very much a discussion it's not a
discussion about Microsoft and Microsoft
technologies per se often these are
issues where we find we're working in
partnership with colleagues or other
companies who have precisely the same
questions and in many ways it's a
dialogue and we're both groping towards
understanding what the real issues are
what the societal reactions might be and
how we find our way through some of
those questions so for example topics
might be information technology and
healthcare it's easy to imagine a point
in the future where we can run in the
cloud complete biological simulations of
ourselves at the genetic level the
genetic data has been collected what
would be the implications of that for
health care medicine will become
personalized the medical treatment would
be optimized to a model of view maybe we
can run those models faster
in real time and actually predict what
genetic disorders you might be
susceptible to and maybe your job
physicians will be able to discuss with
you treatments consequences and so forth
a very different dynamic to the way they
treat us today if we worry about
challenges that we have particularly in
Europe and aging society might we look
to robotics as a solution when when you
become aged there are two varieties of
impairment that strike you and it may be
physical impairment and so you might
think of robotics in the sense of
computing applied to prosthetic limbs
and so forth to maintain mobility and
robotic devices that can help you stay
at home and survive in that environment
longer and the the other source
disability is perhaps losing some of
your mental faculties and again one can
think of robotic systems that remember
things for you remind you to do things
they've just basic stuff like taking
your pills and Joe monitoring and so
forth and that could certainly reduce
the cost to providing health care which
is a very people driven business that
makes it very expensive and a difficult
business to scale but it has all kinds
of implications it's all done by Machine
you've lost the social connection and
that's not a very attracting either so
these are the kind of issues that I
spend my time talking about
understanding some of the the policy
questions some of the implications and
trying to help politicians civil
servants others think through some of
those future scenarios so that we don't
put artificial roadblocks in the way
today and where there are things that
are going to need public debate and
understanding we get those issues on the
table early enough so that we don't have
some of these silly last-minute panics
and uneducated discussions that have
been to the detriment of other
technology areas one thinks of just be
modified food and so forth so that's
what I've had my time doing and when I'm
not doing that my two passions outside
of work are old railway engines and old
aeroplanes I restore aeroplanes from the
1920s and early it's like raui engines
for the 1920s and earlier i fly
airplanes for the 1930s and later that
seems the right default because the
steam engine was in decline from the end
of the 1920s and the aeroplane was
somewhat improving the oldest one I fly
was
built in 1936 and actually it flies
better than other one I fly that was
built in nineteen fifty so there you go
let's talk about challenges I think one
flows directly from some of the policy
things that I'm doing we are painting a
vision of a world which is ever more
dependent on software and indeed in the
panel this morning we talked about and
the way in which some of the funding
agencies are aligning funding programs
with societal challenges whether it's
smart energy coping with climate change
feeling the aging population so the
research funding is pushing Ford's
solutions that will create those
technologies and so ever more software
and that raises in my mind two very
fundamental questions first of all how
do we make developers more productive
again in the morning sessions we had
several people talking about their
already being a shortage of skilled
professionals to write code and that
that shortage getting more severe so the
the smart developers we have have to be
able to use more stuff faster but also
along with that is obviously the whole
issue that software has to be
trustworthy in a very broad sense if we
are dependent on it it becomes part of a
critical infrastructure and so therefore
we have to trust that it can work that
it is secure that it doesn't contain
bugs and as we all know and that's quite
a big challenge and I think many of the
research programs that we had in topics
like software engineering and so forth
have not really scaled up on we know we
define the software engineering crisis i
think in 80 conference in 1960 when i
was still wearing short trousers we
still have that crisis and what's
different now is the size of a system
that we kind of put as being on the
boundary of what its critical is now
probably measured in hundreds of
millions of lines of code rather than
tens of thousands of lines i have the
curious experience earlier in this year
of revisiting a computer and software
wrote as a schoolboy and discovery the
machine had a limit of a matrix of a
hundred by a hundred was the biggest it
could invert and that took nine hours
one just forgets how software has
expanded
in our period so this is classic
computer science and we need language
advances and tools to make developers
more productive tony has hit upon
parallel computing as a very very big
part of that I absolutely agree it's the
old joke what is an elephant is a mouse
with an operating system what's the
cloud is a lot of mice running around
how we turn it into something bigger is
going to be a big challenge we clearly
have to link formal methods and
engineering practice already in
Microsoft's experience as a product
company and we are having to put both
techniques together industrial
organization and project management
alone doesn't see us through with
releasing our big products and as a
dirty little secret and the microphones
are turned off aren't they windows and
office only change about twenty percent
of the code between releases much of the
rest is code that's come through from
previous versions obviously for
compatibility obviously because the PC
is still the pc so the amount of code
that we're changing is a small fraction
of the whole out of the tens of millions
of lines of code in those products and
but even to make sure that we can
deliver that to the kind of quality
levels of that consumers expect on we
want to achieve we're having to deploy
formal techniques to verify things
alongside good project management of the
people alongside hiring the most skilled
developers we can and we struggle to
recruit all the people we'd need we'd
like to see more progress in those tools
work on our new programming languages
new techniques and so forth is
tremendously important to us and if I
think about how we move away from just
the kind of products that microsoft says
but those that are going to become part
of critical infrastructure then we need
to be much better writing highly
parallel highly decentralized self
repairing things we need to understand
working on software systems where the
model is essentially is one of an
ongoing continuous experiment and that's
certainly something which online
services based on the internet like web
search social networks those are showing
us how to run development models where
you introduce new things in a control
community of just a few million people
and a couple of continents if then you
Polly allow it to expand to the full web
scale and so forth so I think the whole
field of software engineering needs to
address those concerns of what will be
the 21st century methods of building
21st century software and stop trying to
apply 19th century engineering
techniques to 20th century software
problems so that's my my first challenge
the second one is kind of related and
again I've marked a few moments ago that
I got to revisit a mini-computer I use
as a schoolboy young undergraduate in
the late 1960s and it just reminded me
how much the world has changed if i look
at the computing environment that the
current generation of undergraduates
will be trained in it's a world based on
cloud computing a scalable computing
resource of vast power that they can
access that's always on that can store
huge amounts of data for their entire
lifetime and that they can share and
collaborate with colleagues it's a world
in which the way in which they interact
with the computer is increasingly
through what in Microsoft weeds we term
natural user interfaces whether that
touchscreens gesture or speech again one
of one of these experiences that make
sure as the world has changed I bought
home and Xbox with the Kinect for
Christmas you would if you worked in
Microsoft I'd read all the words about
it it wasn't until I watched my family
set it up and realize apart from
plugging it into the wall and pressing
the on button everything from there on
out was done by talking at it and waving
at it and gosh it wasn't just doing
dictation it wasn't just doing simple
command the whole setup of that system
was done using anything but a keyboard
in the mouse actually it's the first
games console I've actually to play the
games because I'm not terribly good at
these handling things so we're seeing
significant changes in the user
interface and a user interface where the
computer is watching us all the time it
is very kind of science fiction Star
Trek II but potentially the computer is
moving from being a tool we pick up and
use to do a job to being something which
surrounds us and kind of steps in an
assist when it thinks it's appropriate
to do so
and so the dynamics are changing if I
couple that with what I'm seeing in many
projects in the microsoft research labs
which I jokingly described as inference
replacing algorithms geminis
undergraduate you learnt smart
algorithms for classic problems like
sorting parsing and so forth I now see
those challenges being taken on by my
colleagues in machine learning yeah we
do natural language translation by
machine learning statistics of one
language to another by looking at the
the same text in two languages and so
forth and I'm seeing an increasing
amount of data-driven computing going
through those inference systems building
technologies that give the impression of
being very smart and intelligent and I
don't think I've falling in the trap of
the old vision of artificial
intelligence the machine is just
grinding the data but it can do some
pretty cool stuff doing that in a very
helpful way and if I couple that with
the user interface I see as
game-changing a paradigm going on around
me as when the personal computer came
along and disrupted them the mini
computers and the mainframes that
defined the undergraduate program when I
was a student so again how do we design
and build these systems is a big
question am I call to action there is I
think we could learn a lot by looking at
how the computer games industry which in
some senses at the front of many of
these transitions how they couple
creative people from the world of media
artists designers graphics designers
musicians and so forth to create their
software alongside the computer
scientists who do the event simulation
or the physics of the basic game how do
we bring those two communities together
because of our technology is becoming
more humanistic more more ambient if you
like and there's all words we've had in
our vocabulary for a long time but I
think the technologies have finally come
together we can deliver these systems I
think the committee is going to become
more of a social animal more of a
humanistic animal and so some of the
arts and humanities expertise needs to
come alongside the engineering expertise
how do we do that and then we link it
back to the first question of and we're
struggling to write the software anyway
so I think we have big challenges
but also fantastic opportunities thank
you okay thank you very much Andrew so
we've got their formal proving of
software and also the humanistic
approach and the effects they're off so
now we have Andrew Blake who is recently
appointed managing director at Microsoft
Research Cambridge he's going to give us
his two challenges and calls to action
very good well them I you ask Judith for
us to say first a little bit who about
who we are and so I wanted to say it a
little bit about how I meant how I got
into research I never meant to be a
researcher it was a kind of accident I
studied mathematics and then I got
interested in in device physics and went
and built lasers and things and then I
went and worked for electronics company
never really occurred to me to do
research but while I was at this company
I went to a lecture by a series of
lectures by a man called jolt Russell
who was specializing in image processing
and he showed some pictures of x-rays of
people's lungs which in 1980 were not
very clear are the blurry things and he
was explaining how he represented the
picture some as a matrix and did some
matrix operations on this picture which
all sounds very very dry but then what
came out of that was a clearer picture
and I thought it was rather marvelous
that this some rather abstract and
cerebral mathematics could look so
beautiful on the page and was inspired
by that and started to look for
opportunities to do that kind of work
myself so i went to i was in edinburgh
at the time and edinburgh university was
one of the pioneers of artificial
intelligence which was actually having a
bit of a dip around nineteen eighty
artificial intelligence is a term which
has gone up and down rather a lot and
sometimes you can say with pride and
other times you don't really want to
mention but that's what you work on but
actually you know on balance I think I'm
quite proud of the term artificial
intelligence and
especially as our colleagues in biology
you know manfully trying to map out the
physiology of the brain I think I think
it's fair to say I finally it pretty
difficult to explain how intelligence
works so I think we as as software
people have our own metaphors for
information processing and I think we
actually have a very good stab at
getting a deeper understanding of what
intelligence really is and that was what
inspired me and I got into building
machines that did vision which in 1980
was a little bit hopeless I'm typical I
know that there are be getting into
mercury delay line memory story soon but
a typical image took me 24 hours to
process on a PDP whatever 1134 and so
that didn't seem like anything that
you'd be doing in anger and making money
out of at the time I did actually go to
a parallel processing has been mentioned
as a theme I did actually go to UCL
around 1981 i guess it was where they'd
built a very special parallel computer
called the clip for doing image
processing and i'd written a program up
in edinboro the one that took the 24
hours to detect edges of in images and I
put put the load of the program into the
computer put my keys on the table and
move them around and there was the real
live real-time edge detected version of
my keys moving around on the screen i
never saw was beside myself with
excitement because you know to see
something like that in 1981 was really
something now too there was a whole lot
of sort of academic career after that
which i won't go into but a point did
come at which i thought perhaps one
could think about building machines real
live machines that did machine vision
and at that point i think the strategy
which a lot of people who've worked in
artificial intelligence and have seen
practical opportunities of adopters is
that what were failures in artificial
intelligence because of course you know
the the things we try to do in
artificial intelligence don't end up
producing autonomous machines can become
successes when you put them in a new
context
the new context may be that the problem
is somewhat more restrictive than the
general AI problem of how to behave in a
complex world or it may be that a human
is brought into the loop so that the
technology is only assistive whereas
previously it was expected to be
completely automatic and I think there
are many examples in image processing of
course of the ones I'm fond of stuff but
many other areas where things which were
regarded as failures in artificial
intelligence I'm the whole field of
machine learning is like that become
successes when you constrain them in
that way so I guess the last
biographical thing I want to say is well
now I've inherited this laboratory from
Andrew and his predecessor Roger and
they've spent 13 years putting together
what is really I would say a very
sophisticated institution and with a lot
of talented people in it and as I think
Andrew said in his taught right at the
beginning of the day that it's all
founded on the belief in basic research
and that the way to make a powerful
laboratory even one that is having a
practical impact is nonetheless to build
a research laboratory that is based on
belief in basic research and being
embedded in the research community
that's all of you and playing a full
having offer a full life playing a full
part in academic research and I totally
believe on that but of course I'm also
very interested in how that foundation
of basic research can feed technical
innovation in a company like ours like
Microsoft and so I think for me the
challenge over the next few years is to
sort of pursue those twin tracks to hold
true to the faith in basic research
Roger actually absolutely believe but
also to push through the innovations now
as from my as for my challenges well
actually andrew has set the scene very
well for me I mean his second challenge
is closely related to both of my
challenges so the first one is to do
with I guess what is coming to be call
coming to be called natural user
interface and that is that you know
we're getting now machinery which is
capable of responding to
um humans in morph more flexible and
more subtle ways and so the Kinect
system which has been developed for for
gaming commercially I think of as being
the last inner the most recent in a line
of innovation in human-computer
interaction so you know we have green
screen and come online years ago and
then we had mouse and windows and more
recently we've had touch and multi-touch
and finally what we have is this kind of
no touch paradigm where you can move and
act and those those movements are I
picked up and we have kind of action as
a distance and it's not just the visual
side of that but all of the other
technologies that go with that so I
guess it's probably not been made so
much of it inside the Kinect camera
there's very sophisticated speech
understanding and one of the things that
doesn't work very often with speech
understanding is that if you're 10 feet
away from the microphone try it with
your mobile phone if it does speech
recognition to call up your contacts you
will find that a 10 feet it's not
working because the kind of cocktail
party effect and the problems of
reverberation which we take for granted
because somehow without two ears we're
doing an amazing job of dealing with
that objectively is a horrible problem
and if you're a machine what you hear in
a reverberating environment is you know
infinite numbers of images of me and all
the walls all talking at once with
delays and it's horrific problem and
underneath the Kinect camera you won't
see it unless you look very hard is an
array of microphones which in some ways
is beginning to do what we do without
two years that is to unpick all of these
echoes so that's just one example of the
sophisticated technology that is part of
the new landscape but there's also I
tracking companies like Toby may make
fantastic I trackers they've just
released a laptop which has eye tracking
in the screen so this is something which
i think is relatively unexploited in
user interface there's also in motion
detection the MIT Media Lab have some
amazing demonstrations of subtle tea in
discriminating human emotions which is
we based partly on autism research
believe it or not we're of course a lot
of the study is about failure to do to
detect emotions on the faces of other
people the me allowed even have a an
amazing demonstration where you open
your laptop and in the bottom right-hand
corner it'll tell you how fast your
heart is beating I just couldn't believe
it when I first saw it although you know
now I've had time to think about it I
guess it's not quite so surprising but
it you can can look at you with its
webcam and tell you your heart rate is
pretty amazing so there's quite a
portfolio of sensors emerging and I
think this is my challenge in this
department I think it's a huge
opportunity to make new kinds of
computers the kinds of embedded
computers that Andrew was talking about
that are where you don't necessarily
think of them so much as computers
they're sort of more part of your
environment and machines that just react
in a way that you expect them to react
but what is going to be the killer
paradigm in no touch computing I think
we really don't know I think we're at
this you know it took a long time after
the invention of the touchscreen to
invent what we now recognize as killer
paradigms that everybody loves in touch
and multi-touch and I think we're only
at the beginning of that with new and I
I dare say it'll take another ten years
and it'll take the the thinking of the
whole computer science community I
believe to before we understand what's
the what's the way to use these these
interfaces now I've taught rather a lot
so for my second challenge i'll just say
very briefly what I think it is and that
is the other another theme that Andrew
mentioned is machine learning and that
machine learning is being built into so
many different systems now especially
systems that we interact with on on the
web collaborative filtering systems that
prioritize information and unfortunately
the and this again harks on a theme that
both Tony and Andrew raised
unfortunately this technology is not at
the fingertips of developers I mean it's
a at the moment it's a sophisticated
technology that you need at least a PhD
in machine learning
to know that to be able to manipulate
this and so the question is how will
this ever get into the mainstream of
software development and I think it has
to get there in order to implement
intelligent systems or systems with
intelligence in the kind of volume and
ubiquity that we need but machine
intelligence technology is anything but
mainstream for software developers at
the moment thanks thanks very much
Andrew so now we have Peter Lee our last
speaker peter is a distinguished
scientist that's a special designation
within Microsoft and also managing
director of our Microsoft Research
Redmond lab he's going to come up here
Peter I'll stay seated you're gonna stay
see them do you want me to show your
spread let me show you square all right
hold on I've got a square for Peter and
why don't I start while you're doing
that so so thank you for having me here
it's very exciting i am i'm new to
Microsoft and Microsoft Research having
just started my six month in in the
company so I'm learning a lot as Judith
mentioned I'm the managing director of
the Redmond lab which is in my
experience and probably most of your is
a pretty large place about 350 PhD
researchers and engineers but one of the
shocking things is within Microsoft it's
a tiny blip of almost nothing and that's
actually a very nice place to be because
we're very high impact high impact out
of proportion with our size so the joke
i like to say is that when new graphical
element needs to be added to microsoft
office they'll hire 350 people just for
that and so so we're not not too big so
before I came here I was for a long time
for 22 years faculty member at Carnegie
Mellon University in the computer
science department and and at the end
the head of computer science I I like to
say that that's a cat hurting job and so
I was hurting a lot of cats of course in
the University I had the job of herding
cats but no authority to do anything
with them after President Obama was
elected I joined a small team in
Washington to restart computer science
research at DARPA which is the blue sky
research agency for the Defense
Department and and there I had absolute
military authority and quite a bit of
funds but not as many smart people so
very few cats to heard there and so now
i'm at Microsoft Research and I have a
great deal of authority and lots of cats
to hurt by the prime directive that I'm
not allowed to do any hurting and so
I've referred to this as the Nirvana of
research management because in fact the
job very simply is to try to hire the
best people make sure that all of our
researchers and engineers are fully
resourced and then just get out of the
way and and in fact not to try to tell
people what to do and that's a very nice
really nice job to have now I I can't
actually describe to you what my job is
because I'm still learning it but I do
have a way of looking at research in
computer science that i think is
distinct from research is say the
physical sciences or in mathematics and
so i use a quadrant diagram and so if
you look at the screen here on the
x-axis imagine the spectrum of research
problems or activities spanning a short
term or managed risk kinds of activities
near the origin and as you go out
research activities that are much
riskier or which wich demand patients in
order to see pay off and then on the
y-axis our choices of problems from
reactive problems problems that are
defined for you pain points from product
developers
or societal grand challenges all the way
up to more open-ended search for truth
and beauty let's refer to that as
disruptive problems and so now if you
imagine this whole space of research
problems and I've put names in the
quadrants well in Microsoft Research at
least in redmond the demand that I have
for the research staff is that we have
great impact across this entire space in
all four quadrants and so in the blue
sky area for example we do significant
amounts of just completely open ended
even you might call navel-gazing
research and this is a picture from our
efforts in topological quantum computing
for example which is quite open-ended
and theoretical spending computer
science physics in the mission focused
area we do a lot across MSR so we're
engaged in a holy war with Google for
example in the quality of search and and
we have 40 or 50 phd's working very hard
to to improve our search product and
online products in the sustaining area
these are less time critical but every
bit is important to improve upon every
day and so we do a tremendous amount of
research that is aimed at improving our
internal processes improving the quality
of our foreign language translation
every day improving for today 14
different product groups our internal
code development and code quality
processes and as well as impacting
products for other for our application
developer development communities to do
better and then finally my favorite
quadrant which is the upper left
quadrant is for black vote better term
the game-changing quadrant we're looking
at the world as we know it today what
can we do that would be really
game-changing or disruptive and the work
in newly and then connected
you mentioned is one of the prime
examples here where there was really a
skunk works of sorts to really to change
the way in which we interact today with
game consoles in tomorrow with computers
in more generally and so as I look to
what my primary role is as as a lab
director it's to try to arrange and
organize our lab to achieve impact in
all four quadrants so that's enough
about that so now I Judith asked to look
ahead 20 years and that's I feel a
little sheepish about that because it's
sort of a tall order I'm also feeling
sheepish because we are for Microsoft
people and it sort of gives the
impression that we're the font of all
wisdom and knowledge which is definitely
not true in fact part of the reason that
we exist in microsoft research is to
connect with you and the research
community because you are the font of
all than the ideas and knowledge and we
just organize ourselves to engage as
deeply as possible with you says we can
keep up so as I thought about this
challenge I decided first to go back to
nineteen ninety-one go back 20 years and
see if I can project forward from there
so 1991 turns out to be a very important
year in computing I started to look at
research results and realized I would be
insulting some people by not mentioning
them so I'm not going to talk about
research from 1991 but instead about
major computing achievements so in 1991
in August Tim berners-lee posted his
first executive summary of the new world
wide web project on all dead hypertext
to a stunning array of 214 subscribers
Linus Torvalds on compt at 0 X that
minix posted made a post asking some
questions that were pertinent to a new
kernel project that he was just
launching of course that the current
project became Linux Jim Gosling he had
gone the Sun informed
what he called the green team with the
goal to create a new programming
language for what he was envisioning
would be a new realm of connected
devices that of course became Java there
was a lot of news about Boeing and
Airbus in their new airplanes they were
putting as much as 2 million lines of
code into the airplanes and this was
sparking a huge amount of debate and
interest in the whole realm of embedded
software systems Windows Microsoft
Windows I should mention Microsoft was
transitioning from windows 3.0 3.1
during 1991 with a major revolution
incorporating 16 color graphics for big
breath for big graphics and
incorporating almost 4 million lines of
code and sparking really revolution in
graphical user interfaces on the desktop
as well as setting Microsoft the
corporation on the path of really
starting to worry deeply about how in
the world to manage such large code
bases and then AI I want to say
something ai ai of course leading up to
90 91 there was tremendous optimism huge
amounts of progress but 1991 was a depth
of the AI winter the second day I winter
companies like bliss machines and
symbolic swear were considered to be
dead or dying because ordinary PCs were
surpassing them in strength expert
systems were hitting a wall a scaling
wall they were just proving to be too
brittle DARPA their strategic computing
initiative in 1981 decided to terminate
funding for AI having accused the field
of over-promising and under-delivering
and the Japanese fifth generation
initiative was at that time in 91
clearly failing to deliver real results
and so we see a high point in AI through
the 80 70s and 80s hitting a low point
in 1991 so given all of that where are
we going to be in
in 20 31 which is a crazy thing to think
about and so I did try to think of two
challenges one thing that's not a
challenge is that it looks to me like
today 20 years since 1991 we have fully
emerged from the AI winter and AI is on
the high point again so one could
predict in 20 31 will be in maybe in the
third AI winter so of course by 2031
machines will see just as well as people
may be better they'll hear and
understand as well as people they'll
reason and solve problems as well as
people but they will be accused the
whole field will be again be accused of
under delivering over promising because
people will expect common sense
reasoning causal inference kind of
invisibility lack no need to operate
things and natural mobility in the
physical space and all of those things
will still not be with us in 20 31
that's a provocative prediction I'm
making and I can imagine a headline in
20 31 in April saying something like the
Chinese Robo soccer team has been
knocked out of the first round in the
fifo World Cup sparking a Chinese
government termination of funding for
the program and
maybe this will be the third AI winter
but you know 2051 will be good for you
again so now about software technology
and I I had the advantage of reading the
challenges that were sent around by
email by the other three panelists and
decided to try to take a different
approach in be a little bit provocative
so let me say that in 20 31 we will
start to see quantum machines based on
quantum processes however silicon based
machines will still be with and will
still be the prevalent platform for
computing but reductions in feature size
in energy will mean that the components
fundamentally at all scales from
transistor all the way to large data
center systems will become increasingly
unreliable and that if we're lucky the
components might have some some
probability distribution that will
describe their unreliability but maybe
not and therefore our future computing
systems will either give unreliable
results or will involve programming
systems that are tolerant of that kind
of fault eNOS or uncertainty and so I'm
going to predict that there will be some
need increasingly for uncertainty
tolerance at all scales dealing with in
certainties in massive parallelism as
have been mentioned before in totally
probabilistic and demand driven
computing models without clocks
reconfigure ability and high scalability
and along with those formal reasoning
techniques
in those regimes so that's it's one
prediction second bridge in about 20 31
again trying to be provocative is
software development is plumbing and so
imagine again a newspaper headline use
United States software programmers union
protests lack of tariffs on Chinese
software factory output and so what do I
mean by that well imagine the world in
20-30 one where we have robust and very
usable and clear high-level
specifications for software so ordinary
consumers are able to write down what
they want and you can just outsource to
a software development shop equation the
software that meets that that
specification then there's complete
information symmetry consumers know what
they're getting and producers are able
to charge for that and now met in
gigantic software factories manned by
very large numbers of machines and very
large numbers of people who are able to
reach into massive libraries of
components through advanced search
techniques in auto adaptation and
automatic programming to pluck things
out of these libraries adapt to code put
them all together and deliver it to you
with a proof that this meets the
specification that you you've that
you've asked for so that level of auto
synthesis is is second prediction that I
would have that we get us to a state
where software the creation software and
the installation software becomes as
ordinary in the world as say hiring a
plumber is to outfitting this building
or your house and so as I look at those
two things and I have no idea about
31 if those will come to pass or that
what are the barriers well certainly
there is there will need to be a
continuing respect for really
foundational research and I'm not going
to say basic research because I think
increasingly in computer science there
is no real distinction between basic and
applied research every working computer
science research rhino has both applied
in basic sides to him or herself but
there are foundational concepts concepts
that don't necessarily connect in
obvious ways to the existing practice
and and so one of the things that I
worry about as a community is our
continuing commitment to really
foundational work if we're imagining
looking at computing in a substrate
where every component where every
transistor is unreliable that requires a
level of rethinking and a foundational
respectful foundational work that that I
fear is starting to fade today and so
we'll have to restore that and then
secondly to be open to the idea that we
as if we think of software's plumbing
the idea that we may be able to have
mechanisms to mobilize very large
numbers of people in some coherent way
to solve problems even problems as
complicated as developing new new pieces
of software and so those two things to
me the two barriers I think that I would
think are most important are reinforcing
and restoring respect for foundational
research and computing and secondly
ensuring that we have continuous
engagement and think hard about models
for mobilizing large numbers of people
to solve problems that's it thanks
thank you very much well now you know
why there are executives we finished
bang on time and we're going to now open
the panel to the floor and I think we've
got another Mike somewhere to be
yes there we go so who is going to fire
a question that our people first right
over there
thanks Rachel okay
well you Wow um breve is well such peter
has a mic here we will pass defeat the
first computer science education so it's
a it's an important question I I
obviously in the computer science
research committee we've been fretting
about education for a while one thing
that so I don't have a direct answer but
I do have a remark thats related to to
your question one thing I think that we
sometimes forget about is that
increasingly students who opted to go to
college to study math or science
increasingly that's an odder and odder
choice in our societies it's sort of the
modern-day equivalent of joining a
monastery and and I mean that in a good
way and and another that's another way
of saying that that people who opt to do
that are special in a good way and
sometimes I worry in computer science
when we try to sell computing education
to young people we emphasize too much
the practical you know computer science
is a great education have because it'll
teach you what goes in goes on in your
phone or it will teach you how YouTube
works or at each other the internet
works and that's all great and people do
want to have that kind of real-world
impact but we shouldn't forget that
there's a natural idealism in the best
students who opt for math or science
education that is attracted to the awe
and wonder of the universe and is
interested in more esoteric ideas and
concepts and so one so I always feel
like one element that's missing in our
marketing of computer science to young
people is that we don't whereas we seem
afraid to talk about the esoteric in our
field and we have a lot of things what
can
morrissey turkey video with turing
machine and the idea of limits on
computation and we hardly ever talk
about those things when we sell our
field I'd like to build on on those
thoughts and perhaps European eyes them
we really do have a community I think to
engage with schools to have school
teachers talking about computing and to
do that we have to make the discipline
attractive and I think we need to do
more than just additional talking about
programming and algorithms if we can
talk about some of the challenges in
computing if we can talk about some of
the applications on where they're going
in a my own experience when I was
running the the Cambridge lab we started
a a Christmas lecture for local schools
and we talked about somewhere more
exotic research and we got fantastic
feedback from the teachers and kids who
attended which all down to we didn't
know computer scientists did that that's
interesting and so as we as we run this
thing from year to year we kind of put
less and less traditional computing in a
more more of some of the applications
some of the ways which computing ideas
are being applied to two other fields so
I think we have a huge education task
within the education community and we
have to reach out and help schools
understand this they're not going to
find it from the cells and so things
like student ambassador schemes to so
forth then I think the the other huge
challenge we have is as is a terribly
male-dominated industry there aren't
enough girls in computing current spot
Jones gave her a wonderful talk when she
was collecting for a special accolades
was the end of her life she said
computing is too important to be left to
the boys I think she was spot-on that is
something we absolutely have to address
and we have to find out which are the
aspects of computing are attractive to
the females and will bring them into
this splint what are the topics that
they want to work on and contribute I
think there's a lot of leadership in the
u.s. in the emerging economies they I
think of doing a much better job in
Europe we're very much lagging behind
that area I think it's something we
absolutely have to address because we're
missing out on half
just just a couple of comments I was
very taken by Kenwood's talk this
morning about Gadgeteer and teaching
computing through two systems like that
and in our microsoft research
connections we've had an institute for
robotics for teaching where you give
students robot which they learn
programming by programming a robot which
is slightly more interesting perhaps
than than a traditional platform and we
also have a games for learning institute
where actually can you teach
mathematical concepts to ten-year-olds
by using games this is part of this
agenda called the gamification of
education being somewhat old and I'm
slightly skeptical of that but maybe
that's me being old one thing idea I
liked was in a recent book by Gordon
Bell and Jim Gemmell called Total Recall
it's about the idea that he was
recording every part of his life so he
could record the lectures he grew to
called the examinations the material was
available to tutors they could find out
where they the student had problems they
could go and intervene the student could
go back and relook at the lecture again
it was actually storing all this sort of
relevant personal data that you can go
back and review and then add to as you
go along and i found that attractive and
conceivably something that would
actually play a role in the future well
first of all i think i would like to say
that we should reinforce the theoretical
but parts of computer teaching a little
bit in tune with your idea and my reason
for saying is is because it lasts better
i think some of the more the detailed
practical things that we teach which
across people need to know they come out
of date more quickly but actually we are
teaching young people ways of thinking
as much as as particular skills which
neat in some ways to last them for life
and we're teaching them as a time when
it's a unique time when that they're
uniquely able to pick those
pick those things up the other thing I
wanted to say is I think computer
science may have overcompensated on the
business verse of a business of discrete
versus continuous mathematics and you
know there was a sort of rebellion a few
decades ago when the computer science
departments were breaking free of
mathematics department and they wanted
to show that you know they were
different than what they did was
discrete mathematics and in doing that
they've given away a lot of the the fun
that is based on continue on analysis
essentially two engineers and other
disciplines and certainly my experience
of teaching in Oxford was that the and I
was teaching in an engineering
department was that students were really
turned on by some of the stuff that was
based on continuous mathematics because
the applications were so inspiring and
also because it is a whole kind of tool
set for modeling which you absolutely
absolutely need to know to do a whole
range of things like scientific
computing and the business of
understanding uncertainty which has
become so important so you know
continuous mathematics bring it back
I don't mind Ian Phillips from arm I've
got a little bit of a problem with the
consistency of the the uses of
terminology so we're talking about
mathematics and then we're talking about
computation and then at some stage
somebody is talking about computer and
the next time they're talking about
piece of hardware I have a problem that
that basically says that when you have a
take a smartphone you're actually
talking about an optimized package of a
implementation of effectively a
mathematical model the model is
partitioned such that it runs on various
component platforms inside that so the
the radio for example is a mathematical
model starting off from an analog signal
which appears on an input and it's
processed sooner or later it may very
well be digitized it's going to be fed
through some degree of processing some
of which is dedicated neither of which
will be lets say computer engine
assisted and I think that the the
overall system however is the design
process then is a process of
understanding what the target processing
required is an optimized design is
achieved when the mapping of that
algorithm to appropriate components
within the system is adequate not as
good as it could be but good enough to
meet the non functional aspects of the
spec would you guys like to comment on
any of that
I mean could you crystallize that into a
question okay the question is is there
such a thing as software a computer a
computer science or such or is it only a
process of mathematical analysis and
mapping sliding and summers I've been
having a debate in the UK actually as to
what some of us in the UK but having a
debate as to what computer science is as
a discipline Idzik mathematics is it
engineering I think one of the
fascinating things from when i ran the
cambridge lab and grew it from the 40
people it was when i first arrived to me
and people 40 hace falta my hand it over
to to andrew and was how we found
ourselves adding alongside computer
scientists and psychologists
ethnographers designers a whole range of
other talents and that we have to bring
together and so i think writing software
is more than a mathematical process and
just relying on formal techniques i
think is insufficient I don't think full
techniques resolve fitness for purpose
they tell you what you've built match
the specification but you still have a
question of having specified something
useful or or exciting so you have to
look more broadly there's certainly a
very strong engineering aspect and I
thought Peter was hinting a lot at an
engineering and the way we design
systems to make the more tolerant or
low-level failures and so forth I I
think of myself as more an engineer than
perhaps any other discipline because I'm
hopeless at maths I'm not a very good
scientist so engineer is the last refuge
or that particular kind of scoundrel so
yes I think it is it is very mixed in
the the disciplines of the organization
and I think one of the challenges
perhaps for the theory community is to
find the right blend between theory and
pragmatic
and it's interesting in some of the work
that colleagues in the Cambridge lab
have been doing on Sapa verification for
low-level software in the operating
system while they're not necessarily
able to prove correctness in every case
their tools can quite often say this is
an interesting piece of code I can't
unravel it and you parachute in an
expert at that point who can bring other
skills to bear and that's in some
situations you go up and say that's a
broken formal tool it doesn't quite do
the job but actually deploying a tool
that does quite a lot of heavy lifting
and can point to the places where it
needs more information is quite useful
so yes I think we have to bring
pragmatics engineering design all those
things to bear on how we think about the
production software I agree with all of
that and not to be impolite but I think
it's a silly question and the I hope you
take that in the right spirit let me
explain first of all as academics and i
still count myself as an academic that
hasn't been beaten out of me one thing
that we are also susceptible overly
susceptible to is worrying about
taxonomy and text on amaizing everything
and so so let me tell you a story from
my childhood I grew up in a household
with a physicist as a father and a
chemist as a mother computers in high
school started to come interesting to me
but it was clearly conveyed to me that
computers were just a tool for the real
intellectual pursuits of the physical
sciences when I went to college not
actually being attracted to physics I
become a math student which was
definitely second tier status
intellectually but at least it wasn't
computers and and I became a
had the math degree and then I ran
across the early work by Dan Scott and
Chris first rachy where they were using
about information systems and about
various conundrums in set theoretic
interpretations of computable functions
and at that moment at least as a math
student it became very clear to me that
the notion of computation was something
new that hadn't been contemplated before
in a serious way in exactly the same way
at least since gödel and entering and
that there was something fundamentally
new and whether you want to call it
mathematics or computer science or
software or whatever it sort of beside
the point there was something new for
Humanity to discover and understand and
i think it's therefore completely
important and respectable discipline
calm business making one comment well i
think is the difference there's a whole
army of people who do work on p rams
which assumes that you can have large
numbers and you can get instantaneous
access and so on you write all sorts of
algorithms I think that's mathematics
what is real is when you have a system
where you have multiple processes but
you have network contention you have
memory contention you have cash
hierarchies then you have to do some
engineering so actually that's I think
the difference I vote for
okay Stephanie anything technical
university of berlin i think it's very
hard to predict the future and that's
why the discussion is also a bit
difficult so but i would like to give
you one question which is also very
difficult to answer i mean we have been
talking about all our research being
more or less incremental yeah and i
think that's what we experience now yeah
we see that we have incrementally
progress yeah and we will see how we try
to imagine how the world would look like
in 20 years from now can you imagine
anything any technological breakthrough
which would change the way in which we
do our science today or our our business
today or profession today one example
would be P equals NP but just one
example can I give you another which is
I think when when ok nanotechnology
becomes real we're talking 20 years in
the future and when we have actually
Peter was talking about the unreal you
can't shrink the present technology
because they will get unreliable when
you only have a few electrons in the
gate but when you get down to devices
with the few atoms you'll do things
differently and that will hugely change
things and for example at the moment we
have all this worry about multi-core and
power log computing maybe it'll be
different and energy loss will be not
the problem when you get down to you
know devices with few atoms so I think
nanotechnology is going to be a big big
driver in the financial nanotubes
okay why are you gonna mash so i'll give
you one other which i think comes in
down the same path and one of my
colleagues in cambridge luca cardelli is
looking at this when we have systems
that self-assemble and build themselves
from a specification he's looking at in
the context of DNA DNA is a system that
knows how to replicate assemble and
build new structures and it works at the
gradual arity arm atoms which is what we
seem to need because we're struggling to
build silicon at these fine grains so I
think if we can build self-replicating
systems that can be given a
specification then go build something
else that will change the game
considerably for us too but DNA may not
be the right route but it's a nice world
in which to experiment with those ideas
does it work yeah I was going to ask a
simple question it could be also
difficult I don't know Microsoft is a
software company and I wonder whether
you know what the main source of income
for Microsoft would be in 20 years which
software system I mean I was at recently
at the executive retreat and Steve
Ballmer interestingly described the
company as a devices and services
company I'm confident we will have
something will call an operating system
and we're call it windows I'll be very
surprised it has many lines of code in
common with the thing that we call an
operating system of windows today so
first of all I hope it exists I just
invested in a house in the Seattle area
and the you know I think Tony mentioned
services and it does seem to me that
that we could see a real proliferation
of platforms and devices in it
increasingly Microsoft will want its
software on a wider and wider array of
devices both devices that it works on in
bills but also devices other people will
build in and won the bike and so that
seems to me to imply at least in the
very long term that that a software
company like Microsoft and any other
software company will at least have to
have some part of the business that is
able to respond very quickly to to
satisfying new specifications I think
you can rest assured that any hints as
to what this business will be that you
hear from this panel will be incorrect
because otherwise we would have we
wouldn't be here we'd be rushing off and
doing it
yeah sorry Yong Bosch chalmers
university of technology very
interesting presentations by all of you
I very much enjoyed listening to what
you were sharing with us but I did
notice that you take took a very strong
technology driven innovation approach
you came from what are the physical or
technical possibilities that will be
created in the coming 20 years now last
time I checked Microsoft was a
for-profit company so I want to pick up
a little bit on where the last question
left it off we've now been talking about
technology but what are the consumer or
customer use cases that you think you
will be solving 20 years from now
because I think that dos use cases or
those jobs that you solve for your
customers are the ones that your
customers will in the end pay you for
and consequently you'll be generating
your revenue from so I would very much
like to get your perspective on what are
the new jobs or the new use cases that
you believe you will be solving for
customers in the coming decade or two
decades I think it's clear what some of
the big opportunities are I guess one of
the biggest ones is health and that's
something which in the last few years
the company has taken a big interest in
and you know the other big ones are the
ones that matter a lot to people
generally and that's transport and
energy and you know I think those are
going to engage a lot of serious
attention in the next 20 years I will
pick up that bull run with a bit further
I think andrew is spot-on am and indeed
if you look at the company you'll see we
have some product groups now who are
much more aligned with verticals than
the traditional horizontal view of
Microsoft I think about health care
solutions group what is interesting in
that model is we look for opportunities
where technology innovation of the kind
that we know how to do can change the
game that's so
the case in healthcare healthcare we see
today as essentially a very expensive
people driven industry that hasn't if
you like had the productivity forces
drive through it that administration and
clerical work how they were affected by
the personal computer and personal
productivity so in some sense the
question is you know where are the other
worlds where we can do windows and
office to those worlds by the use of
technology that changes the way in which
the work is done typically driving
towards productivity driving to higher
levels of service and certainly health
care is a very strong candidate we
already have a group in that area things
such as smart energy environmental
monitoring and so forth transport and
are also likely to be equally important
and so quite a big focus of out of our
research agenda is starting to take more
of that kind of vertical dimension and
from working with colleagues in
universities working with colleagues and
other companies that's how we're hearing
some of those use case scenarios I think
fundamentally Microsoft is a technology
company and we will be bubbling up
technologies and seeing which ones stick
and ones that stick will run as fast as
we can that is the nature of the company
and I think fundamentally Moses in the
company do believe that technology leads
innovation but the trick is to as you
see it take off in an area to run with
it very very quickly and exploit it
these are I also agree with these
comments and these are examples of
computing becoming more and more
important than infecting more of our
lives in the background so the fastest
part of the Microsoft's business right
now are in the enterprise and in the
server spaces which are things that
consumers don't feel or touch or see and
in health care and energy even in the
whole initiative towards natural user
interaction the whole idea of a consumer
operating a computer starts become far
less prevalent and instead computing is
just all around you you know at your
service supporting the things that give
you your job or business or
or that your your life needs and so it
seems to me the debt there's just huge
growth opportunities there and it seems
that that will start to dominate what
Microsoft does at least long-term yes
just I think largely an agreement with
the vertical picture that Andrew and
others are painting when I was dean of
engineering I came from the electronics
computer science department and you know
I was trying to give a vision for
engineering of the future to my civil
engineering department aeronautical
engineering ship science and all these
traditional engineering disciplines and
they didn't really like my vision very
much because really the building is
really going to be a smart distributed
computing system similarly a airplane is
a flying distributed computing system
and really ICT is going to be in
everything and software will be in
everything and I think Microsoft will
find opportunities you're already seeing
in Microsoft has various deals with Ford
for example with voice controls in in
cars in the automotive industry and I
think that's just the beginning of these
type of applications
so Ursula Martinelli ER today mentioned
one of the dangers of the potential
dangers of using technology and I was
wondering if you think in 20 years time
computer science and so that I think
that the speaker said well you know we
shouldn't really worry too much about
how the how the technology might be
abused I wonder if in 20 years time we
should be getting more involved in the
in in in talking about or discussing the
ethical issues in the danger in which
technology might be used because I think
in the way same way as doctors might
talk about the ethical treatments and
technologies that they develop maybe we
should also be debating and talking
about and thinking about and taking it
on board as one of the things that we
should also be discussing with society
yes I think I feel very strongly about
this point in fact I was describing to
the speaker after that that the when I
was at DARPA i arrived at DARPA just
after the Iranian elections in 2009 and
it became apparent that the Iranian
government was using good technologies
technologies to help detect intrusions
into computer networks in order to hunt
down and prosecute dissidents who are
trying to access sites like Twitter and
so you see that that that was a new idea
and that the computing community failed
to think about the potential miss uses
of technologies or just to assume likely
that that it was this was these were
good Technologies and today in computer
security research community if you go to
you know the Oakland security conference
there are some implicit assumptions that
for example eliminating anonymity on the
internet will make the internet a safer
place well where we know there are
repressive regimes that would exploit
those very same technologies to suppress
freedom of speech and freedom of
assembly and so I think as a community
that we have a long way to go to have a
high
a sense of awareness and sensitivity to
the potential bad uses of the things
that we invent yeah just a quick comment
I think that privacy and and ability to
and remove things from the web is going
to be a real issue in the future I think
that many of my kids and their friends
with their recordings on Facebook will
live to regret some of those and
actually removing things for getting
things on the web is extremely difficult
there are now business opportunities in
the US the thing called reputation
defender in the UK my colleagues
Southampton have a startup company
called garlic which actually finds out
what what's on the web about you and
maybe you can do something about it so I
think privacy not only with respect to
you know medical records and things like
that but privacy that you want is going
to be a very complex issue and you can
take the view is privacy is over get
over it but I I think most people will
not wish to do that so it's related to
the security issues and tracking people
down and all this sort of stuff so
complicated questions I don't think any
of us know the answer I agree that there
are no easy answers questions but I
think the question behind the question
was should the research community engage
in these in these issues and I think the
answer is absolutely yes I'm part of my
role these days is to have some of those
conversations and a lot of it is groping
together with the pinnacle community on
understanding the issues and you it may
be the case that by the time and Tony's
kids are in the workplace or certainly
minded a little bit younger everyone has
an embarrassing photograph on facebook
so it's not an issue that's that's a
very simplifying assumption that may not
be the case and when we talk about
protecting people from the damage that
Internet can do to them one solution is
to think of an log with the way we
protect the roads and you can what
anyone can walk on a sidewalk or a
pavements in most countries so
in Europe if you want to get in a car
you have to apply to the state for a
license because a car is a more
dangerous thing it's faster and you can
wipe more people out in the car and you
can sir des trian and if you want to
drive a big truck that moves lots of
things around you have to have even more
licensing privileges and even more tests
and it may be you're audited every year
to make sure that you've maintained your
level of skill and you could imagine
applying that to Internet service
providers and even Internet users but
then you've established entity and that
has all the other associated risks and
Europe has sensitivities around the
abuse with density going back to the
last century so these are very difficult
challenges and we can just duck the
question but then I think the
politicians will invent stupid rules
that don't work and I think if we get a
discussion about the issues out in the
open earlier there at least can be
informed debate and people can
understand some of the risks I think we
are in the dilemma that many sciences
are everything we produce has a good
side of a dark side and let's be upfront
about that let's talk about some of the
ways in which we can mitigate the bad
effects and some of the ways in which
governments at a global scale have to
think about regulation and codes of
practice and to make the world a safe
place for technology I don't think you
can stop the pace of development and so
you've got to respond to these things
and respond early rather than late
two